and now 9 more urban dictionary
definitions you need to know sparking
spooning with an erection Barry and
Elaine's cuddle time turns into sparking
after two glasses of wine store
d'oeuvres free samples at the grocery
store your family is so poor they eat
store d'oeuvres for dinner
clutch oven to fart in a car full of
people
Jenny clutch oven the carpool because
she didn't get shotgun man stand to
stand outside a store while your
significant other shops inside Barry did
a man stand outside Dillard's while
Elaine tried on girdles nerd Jack to
dominate conversation with talk of
obscure passion Frank nerd jacked
Thanksgiving dinner again with his
Doctor Who fan fiction Irish handcuffs
holding an alcoholic drink in each hand
can you get the door for me bro I've got
the Irish handcuffs over here man third
an older man who date's younger women
uncle Ted bought tickets to the Katy
Perry concert because he's a total man
third mom petition competition between
mothers Rebecca spent $900 on
christening photos to win her mom
petition with Annie interesting not
interesting at all the only thing I
could say after Gerry's boring story was
Oh interesting for more definitions
visit urbandictionary.com while you're
there be sure to look up check sting
it's kind of gross